karl lagerfeld l'a quitté et je veux
vous montrer que chose qu'on doit
toujours avec des lunettes et en 2006
dans l'émission en aparté diffusée sur
canal+ il expliqué pourquoi il ne
voulait pas montrer ses yeux est ce que
vous savez ce que vous connaissez la
réponse ou pas regarder parce que moi
ont ramené de se regarder que je peux
voir vos yeux non ça fait partie de nous
tous non non non je suis myope vous avez
les murs quand il enlève les lunettes
ils ont un regard de chien gentil je
n'ai pas un magnifique regard les
mioches voilà et c'était juste pour ça
en fait qu'il avait des yeux il épices
et les ulémas bourgueillois file alors
karl lagerfeld
il était en 1982 il a été nommé
directeur artistique de chanel en 1982
c'est incroyable et il a dégainé sa
fortune à sa chatte choupette
non mais c'est pas du tout une bonne
mais sans rigoler alors regardez il en
avait parlé d'ailleurs dans le divan
2015 y est c'est ça c'est un truc de fou
regarder quand vous expliquer cette
espèce de passion vous avez maintenant
pour un animal c'est d'une chose il il
n'attend du jamais passé la baby que ça
pourrait m'arriver
ça me fait rire à mon propre sujet
presque
hélas après de mes propres petites
fortunes qui m'arrive quelque chose
c'est une héritière la personne qui sont
créé pas d'elle et ben ne sera pas dans
la meilleure si vous arrive quelque
chose c'est votre héritière choupette
ouais non elle a jeûné pub qu'elle a
fait l'argent et je ne prends pas c'est
me exprès pour elle et oui mais
justement il avait comme grand ami brad
que nick est un mannequin qui était un
de ses proches et qui a un fils une
somme qui a 9 ans et qui sera aussi
héritier alors eh oui mais je faisais ça
vous savez à qui appartient choupette
alors parlez bien fort vous avez acquis
remarque un chouette à qui appartient à
tous pas karl lagerfeld non abati
j'avais connu à matisse que j'embrasse
baptiste alarmant c'est qu'il est le
propriétaire de la chatte
donc si c'était lui la chatte et qu'elle
achète
la lutte au vert du coup les biens par
ses conseillers
comme c'est la norme est sérieusement
non mais comme il est prometteur de la
chatte et que najat va hériter donc de
l'argent de gamme fait mon propriétaire
séduit c'est lui qui va récupérer
l'argent excuse moi l'état qui certes il
est plus petit
en fait il avait demandé à une époque
donnée à karl lagerfeld de garder ce
fait karl lagerfeld c'est tellement
attachés à chaque mois on voit que
lorsque vous avez déjà travaillé car la
garde en moi j'aurais rêvé c'est ma
grande frustration mannequin à chaque
fois j'ai fait tous les castings de
chanel et à chaque fois il a retoqué
j'ai juste une fois travaillé pour lui
quand il avait sa collection karl
lagerfeld pour karl lagerfeld esclave il
a travaillé pour chloé pour chanel pour
fendi pour jeune marque qui venait de
moi je n'ai jamais rencontré mais on a
une petit un petit truc avec lui et
franchement je l'adoré parce que je vous
expliquais un jour on appelait une
boutique à la radio de sa garde la carf
s y rendent commandes voilà avec jérôme
commandeur on a fait un canular
je déteste ce mot paix où on a fait un
coup au téléphone et on s'est fait
passer pour quelqu'un qui voulait et il
fait pas il s'est fait passer pour karl
lagerfeld et il voulait sortir un
tailleur pour valérie benaïm ou chemise
et et figurez vous que la classe de karl
lagerfeld
il a pris le truc et le lendemain il a
fait livrer à la radio sur europe 1 le
tagueur pour valérie bénaïm c'est encore
franchement vigilance parce
qu'effectivement on avait fait un sketch
ou bossa où il joue et karl lagerfeld et
où il m'aurait caché il appelle sa
propre boutique il engueule la fin soit
disant et il apprend cette semaine c'est
l'arrière il c'est vrai que c'est une
immense marque karl lagerfeld près
d'élégance c'est vrai que voilà on dans
la mode c'est pour moi c'est la plus
grande star de la mode enfin le plus et
lui qu'on connaît le le c'était un des
seuls dont on disait que c'était une
sorte de mercenaire et ça ne choquait
personne c'est à dire qu'à la fois il
pouvait travailler pour fendi pour
chanel pour sa propre marque
alors que normalement les créateurs ne
font que leur qu'une seule marque mais
pouvait travailler pour plusieurs
marques à la fois et c'est ça passer
comme une lettre à la saison compte bien
sur ces équipes qui travaillent avec lui
seb notamment voilà qui travaillent avec
lui et bien sûr on pense à baptiste
giabiconi qu'est donc ils étaient très
proches et on pense bien sûr à sa
famille et donc à chaud pète on espère
que elle va être récupéré rapidement oui
oui je sais qu'il a fait un très beau
coup avec les jets les jeunes aussi oui
c'est vrai
pour s'éloigner de sa part ça c'est ça
c'est sa classe et c'est fou parce qu'il
est resté au top pendant dix admis
traversé toute l'époque que toute la
mode il a tout inventé en évidence d'une
franchise brutale tout le temps c'est un
vrai personnage
ouais on sait que chanel c'est une idée
qu'on peut réinventer sans cesse c'est
pour ça qu'il avait toujours de la
création nouvelle c'était très beau en
tout cas voilà on voulait lui rendre un
petit hommage ce soir même si aucun goût
l'avait rencontré à oui oui mais
plusieurs fois mais doit rester une fois
pourquoi au plusieurs fois oui d'accord
mais c'est vrai qu'il rencontre tout le
monde mais personne ne l'a